that's right let's let's jump in to this
chocolate universe oh my gosh this is so
good
tastes like definitely I've had this
before tastes like a good generic hot
chocolate that was really sweet
it is really yeah it's really like
creamy damn this is a high standard I
really don't want to stop I think it's a
little too much milk but I'm not mad at
it it's complex
yeah that's what this is complex oh it's
like watery whoa whoa whoa what the hell
was that you like kind of get excited
when you start to taste it and then the
flavor like doesn't ever come goodbye
they mix this right if this is like the
watered down hot chocolate it smells
like campfire Nestle hot chocolate it
tastes richer it's not as chocolatey
though that's the thing
this is the favorite so far yeah it's
like more full-bodied if that's even a
thing for its wine now let's wash I
could down mm-hmm like you know one gulp
looks like the second one which kind of
makes me nervous I don't understand that
was disappointing I know I think this is
the expensive one because this actually
has dark chocolate I would say this is a
cheap one yeah I've never had this
experience in my life where I question
chocolate so much well wait hang on
which is like dark chocolate I guess I
like this one I guess second I would
think this one is like expensive and it
looks like our least favorite one yeah
like I think this could be like a
Gennaro deli lay yeah yeah think about
the chocolate
I think I still like like this like I I
do too
I like this like this is a lot actually
this one this one of course it the best
yeah you listen this first shirt and
that one's cheap too
I think the middle one the third one
yeah and it's still it's still smoking
this is what we discovered today you
don't need money
just get the Swiss Miss its Bob it's a
complex party you're gonna walk in
you're gonna feel like it's a holiday
spirit you know like how there's like
sometimes the little chocolate gunk left
yeah that's the best part
[Music]